depuis le début de la guerre russo
ukrainienne il y a deux mois plus de 300
civils se sont installés en touraine
notamment chez l'habitant c'est le cas
dans cette famille de roche corbeau qui
héberge deux soeurs et un enfant après
une période d'adaptation chacun a trouvé
ses marques en attendant un logement
pérenne florent clavel
bafta
pour communiquer un simple traducteur
ukrainien français sur un téléphone et
beaucoup de gestes et de sourire au menu
donc ce midi pasta des pactes et c'est
diana qui est aux commandes et des de
son fils arthur et de sa demi-soeur
ilona une façon de remercier leurs hôtes
volontaires pour héberger des réfugiés
ukrainien
quand on a regardé la gare télévision au
départ c'est vrai que j'étais je
n'arrive même plus à dormir ça me ça me
prenait au coeur donc on a avec amandine
on a tout fait pour pouvoir intégrer une
famille rapidement chez nous pour des
raisons de place diana et sa famille ont
finalement posé leurs valises chez les
parents de xavier déjà deux semaines de
cohabitation de semaine loin des bombes
originaire de loots qu déjà fui pour
protéger son fils et sa soeur les autres
membres de la famille sont restés se
battre sur place ici les réfugiés tente
de retrouver un semblant de vie normale
les journées ce passe très bien on
apprend le français on cuisine une aide
les hôtes avec nicole on se promène très
souvent dans le village nicole
au gouvernement mon fils dale écoles
mais sert va bientôt égaler également
qu'on s'occupe aussi en dessinant en
peignant donc soit on est extrêmement
reconnaissante
en attendant la location pour demandeurs
d'asile et le droit de travailler pour
diana la famille alves su bien à tous
leurs besoins et des en partie par
l'association touraine ukraine à terme
diana et sa famille pourraient également
avoir leur propre logement
je pense que l'idéal c'est que l'on me
rapproche un peu de tours qui conçoit
voilà qu qu'elle faisait leur
appartement ou leur petite maison je ne
sais pas ce qu'ils peuvent avoir pour
qu'ils marquent la vie continue pour eux
et non serait clos leur parent diana ne
sait pas encore combien de temps ils
resteront sur les couteaux de
rochecorbon sa priorité et celle de la
famille alves préserver au maximum le
petit arthur 70 des horreurs de la
guerre